hello and welcome back to brain review
my name is Caleb Denby and today I
wanted to take you through a game from
the world rapid championship although
this time it's from the women's section
the game was between humpy canary and
not a zig zag NIT see tough name so I'll
be calling her nada these two players
will actually be playing here in st.
Louis very very soon for the Karen's Cup
and so it's interesting to see how they
squared off in this game at the rapid
championship Canario had white and she
chose d4 after East six c4 Knight f6
Knight c3 Bishop b4 we are once again in
a nimzo-indian white shows III as the
line after castles white has a lot of
options here you can felt the bishop you
can develop the knight this way or you
can play Knight d2 and this is a pretty
interesting try part of the the reason
the name is Owen Eunice played is when
the bishop captures its knight on c3
black is hoping to slightly fracture
White's pawn structure and a lot of
lines right bringing this Knight to e2
so early you are saying that you're not
going to fracture your pawn structure
that you're going to recapture with the
knight and black will have nothing in
exchange for giving up the bishop with
that of mines black plays d5 and after a
three the point of whites play black
usually does not capture this but this
night instead choosing to retreat the
bishop to either east 7 or d6 and the
choice between these two is is rather
interesting by coming to e7 white will
probably most likely just take on d5 and
play Knight f4 it will be a very very
you know natural game you have this
classic Karlsbad structure and white
will play like it's a Queens gambit
declined type type structure you're kind
of transposing into a qgd type of game
that in mind though you might notice
that the bishop has another option from
d7 and that's to come to d6 and this is
a try an improved version of the other
one if white plays the same way with C
takes d5 and E takes d5
this night probably doesn't want to come
to f4 it can come to g3 and this Bishop
is much better placed on d6 than a 7
it's out of the way on the e-file for
the rook and this would be a much much
better version for black so in the game
and this is what black chose to do black
chose to put this bishop on d6 aiming
for that improved version however as
always in chess there's usually a
downside to things and the downside to
Bishop d6 is it's daring white to take
more space on the Queen side and that is
done via this move c5 now c5 comes with
tempo on the bishop on d6 whereas if the
bishop are on e7 c5 is much less
attractive because the the pawn the pawn
move would be wasting a tempo you
wouldn't be gaining time on the bishop
now this Bishop does come back to e7 but
White has committed to c5 black is going
to try to prove that this is a bad thing
and meanwhile white is going to try to
prove that the space advantage is quite
useful the natural follow-up for white
is B for supporting this pawn further we
now see c6 from Black Knight f4 a5
trying to break down this structure this
Bishop comes to be 2 it's necessary to
defend this rook otherwise a takes b4
would be winning and now b6 creates even
more tension on this Queen side between
all of these pawns locked on dark
squares at this point white develops her
final piece with Bishop e2 and black
plays an idea we've all seen before
Bishop a6 this is a good Bishop for
white this is a bad Bishop for black so
black aims to trade it off white simply
castles here black develops with Knight
bd7 Genaro takes on a6 rook takes a 6
Queen e2 Queen 8/8 93 and now you kind
of see that the character of the
position black is hoping to open up some
of these lines on the Queen side aiming
to bring her major pieces over and open
these lines find counter play against
what these pawn these ponds which might
be called overextended meanwhile white
is supporting these pawns with her
pieces from behind and we'll be looking
to open things up not only
queenside but rather in the center with
moves like F 3 and E 4 and if white does
achieve this look to show look to open
this long diagonal and then transfer her
pieces to attack the the Kings side and
this is a very very dangerous game games
like this where both sides are playing
on different sides of the board can go
wrong quite quickly and we'll see what
happened here so simply rook the eight
from black is a natural move like I said
you want to open up lines white takes
the time to play rook fb1
supporting these pawns further and now
rook a7 was the slightly strange choice
from black I'm not sure what what the
idea entirely was here
she's delaying opening up the the Queen
side for just a bit not yet showing her
hand however white wastes no time
white continues with f3 and after h6 I
guess creating left for the King but
allowing white to kind of break through
uncontested with this movie 4 and
already you know I would start getting a
little bit nervous with with black here
seeing this the central majority will
not majority just these central pawns
coming through coming down towards
towards my pieces it can be slightly
scary black chose pawn takes e4 white
responds with pawn takes e4 and now nod
I decided this was the correct moment to
open things up on the Queen side and
that she did with both of these pawn
captures now the black major pieces are
entirely revealed and these open files
are going to be aware that the combat is
is taking place but continues actually
Oh black continues actually with E 5 and
this move is actually not not the
greatest it puts this pawn on a square
we can actually kind of be targeted by
by the the white bishop and in addition
to that this space advantage on the
Queen side is going to be very very
uncomfortable
unless black does something about it
almost immediately and so my question to
you viewers is can you find an
interesting line perhaps the sacrifice
really break down this the structure of
the pawns it's a very unique ID well not
unique idea it's a very interesting idea
and one that would have would have been
a quite nice for black-haired you just
totally equalize and get rid of this
these annoying ponds that are cramping
her position okay hopefully you're able
to find it and the idea is rook takes B
for sacrificing an exchange at first
glance it looks like an entire rook is
being sacrificed but of course there is
this nice fork with Bishop takes c5 the
King would have to move and after Bishop
takes b4 the material account is three
pawns to five and White has in exchange
for those two pawns so this position is
actually a pretty nice pretty nice for
black if black doesn't have an advantage
but black certainly isn't worse here the
C pawn will be quite useful it has
passed but our white will have to keep
an eye on it and the black pieces are
all going to be in the game now that
these annoying B 4 and C 5 pawns are out
of the way game might the game might
continuing with something like e 5
Bishop takes c3 but should take c3 and
95 you see this Knight has a very nice
outpost and this Knight can also
contribute to the game either from d7 or
a square like g6 where it looks at
squares like f4 that being said 'if I've
four black this is this opportunity and
now White's advantage is going to start
being felt that that advantage in space
Knight d1 was white choice immediately
pressuring this pawn rook a to
temporarily defends the pawn by pinning
the bishop to the Queen we now see the
knight come back to c3 forcing the wreck
to move again black had the option to
just repeat but instead we see rook
takes a 1 Rick takes a's a 1 and queen
b7 white plays the same idea Knight back
to d1 putting pressure on e5 and now
black plays Queen b5 and already this is
just a very very tough position for for
black these pieces are all being
hampered by White's advantage in in
space
and that advantage is not going anywhere
now that black has missed this
opportunity to capture on before
sacrificing in fact I don't want to go
into the line too much but after 93 this
was really or 93 rather this was blacks
last opportunity to get back into the
game and it's with a very unorthodox
piece sacrifice simply Knight takes e5
and you give up this night for a pawn
and then there's a lot of pressure on
the slightly misplaced white pieces I
don't want to go into this line too much
because it's very very complicated and I
don't fully understand it but this is
what the engine gives as as being equal
instead though she played a very human
move rook da with some similar ideas of
sacrificing but after rook a5 there's no
such luck this Queen has to move and
there's no more pressure on the d3 night
this night now comes to c4 we see night
f8 we see Bishop takes e5 and with the e
pawn falling this is really spelling
disaster for Black Knight e6 Bishop d6
Bishop f8 h3 Knight g5 and now after E 5
White has cemented this Bishop onto the
d6 square at any point white can trade
these bishops and bring this knight into
an even better outpost and we'll see
just that happen pretty quickly here
Knight d5 Queen e1 helps defend this
pawn Queen d7 this Queen now comes to f2
threat to the pawn being removed we see
queenie 6 and at this point white does
choose to snap off this bishop and play
96 now queen g6 comes through queen g3
and it looks like black is actually
finding some counter play here but maybe
a move like f5 was was a missed
opportunity
this Knight can come back to f2 but
after f4 his Queens gonna be in some
trouble and after this Queen has to move
let's say queen d3 black is really
getting a nice attack on the Kings side
here so move like f3 is going to come
and black is actually playing for an
advantage all of a sudden
let's back up and see exactly how that
happens this queen g6 move is actually
very very tricky
it's putting a lot of pressure onto the
White King it's threatening Knight takes
h3 as well and the only move for white
to maintain an edge here was actually
Queen f5 Queen a5 offering the trade of
Queens keeping an eye on this h3 Square
and this would maintain the edge of the
extra pawn
unfortunately for white queen g3 doesn't
do that as we looked fi would be a very
very interesting way to gain an edge
white could also try and in trade but
with all of this pressure on the White
King black it's going to have a very
nice attack that being said a 5 was
missed for black and in fact Knight
takes b4 was her choice while this is
equalizing and regaining the pawn it's
kind of a missed opportunity to go for
this nice attack with f5 of course if
Knight takes b4
the idea is Queen b1 check regaining the
night so instead of night before white
instead chooses Knight f4 queen v1 check
King h2 and now blacks equality was
actually short-lived as now it is blacks
King that comes under fire you see a
very similar setup where the White Queen
is now aimed at g7 and black needed to
realize the danger here because if you
do some nonchalant move which is what
was played some move not really sensing
the danger this move h4 is very very
tough to deal with the knight comes back
to h7 and all of a sudden you're getting
checkmated it's very very difficult to
stop this threat of Queen g7 in fact g6
or g5 are really the only ways to do it
g5 obviously not the ideal solution so
we see g6 instead but now White has a
number of winning moves including the
one plate in the game ISA 'kz just
getting rid of this defender of g6 and
there's not much to be done Knight f6
was played we take H we take f7 this
King comes to h7 trying to defend after
Knight takes f6 Knight takes f6 white is
is simply our queen takes f6 rather
white is this simply winning white
reroutes this rook via a 3 over to f3
and after Queen f2 offering a trade of
Queens now that white is up this very
powerful F pawn we see Queenie five
check pH one another check came back to
h2 and after a repetition white chooses
g3 to defend her King King g7 is played
and now Queen d2 rerouting the Queen
once again black can do nothing better
than to pass
you see rook f2 and Ric e 2 and now
Ricky one blacks or whites being pretty
mean here just kicking the black Queen
around and now that the Queen has left
this diagonal Queen B to check spells
disaster after Ricky eight when there
are threats of checkmate threats of
queening and there's nothing nothing
left to be done for a black to try to
save this game so it was a very
interesting game this time around
between canary and Nana and like I said
they will be facing each other here in
the Cairns Cup so we'll see how that
matchup actually shakes out in classical
chess we've seen a canary prevail in the
rapid chess with this spatial advantage
and not actually missing an opportunity
to get back into the game with all that
in mind thank you so much for joining me
again for game review my name is Caleb
ben b and i will see you in the next
episode